Let's talk to a couple of other people.
Why don't we I mean, it's like we're here,
right?
Why why would we just.
And right now, let's go to Stephanie from
London.
Stephanie from London.
You're on the air.
Oh, no, I'm sorry.
That's Stephanie from Long Island, not London.
Sorry, Stephanie.
Am I on?
Yes, you're on, Stephanie.
Oh, my.
Sorry, this is so surreal for me.
Hi, nice to meet you.
Pleasure.
I just wanted to get your opinion just because
I've been hearing from a lot of pundits that
the capital riot was similar to like 9/11
on how they felt, you know, with, you know,
I guess the terrorist attack, you know, considering,
you know, the actions taken after 9/11 with
the Patriot Act, I guess I just wanted your
opinion on, you know, constitutional law.
So let me see if I can I want to make sure
I've seen floating around that there are some
folks who I guess really they seem more libertarian
than anything else who who are warning that
much like we got the Patriot Act after 9/11,
that we might get something similar because
of the Capitol riots.
Is that what you mean, Stephanie?
Yeah.
You know, just everyone, at least conservatives
I've seen have been complaining about their
constitutional rights being violated, even
though it's not technically a constitutional
violation to lose book deals and be kicked
off Twitter.
But right with the Patriot Act out, what to
what extent should constitutional law be?
I guess.
Waved in, sort of compromising national security.
Well, it shouldn't and it's not.
And so so as you rightly point out, losing
a book deal because of what you did on January
6th is Josh highlighted that that's not a
constitutional issue.
It's not a free speech issue.
It's nothing other than businesses making
decisions when it comes to the FBI putting
out wanted posters and saying, here's the
people we're looking for.
If you have information, let us know there's
no constitutional issue there.
That is something that's been around in the
United States for hundreds of years.
And it's no problem up fears of some kind
of crackdown on privacy because of the January
6th.
Riots aren't they're not misguided.
I'm not seeing evidence that there are attempts
to do that, Stephanie.
So I would hesitate before jumping too deep
in that to see if there's actually such attempts
that are going to be made.
I think that's kind of how I would categorize
the different a follow on effects of the riots.
Yeah, I guess considering like Joe Biden and
Chuck Schumer, like these are all like Democrats
that were for the Patriot Act, I guess I just
sort of am concerned that, you know, after
acts of terrorism, you know, the Constitution
could be used like could sort of like.
You know, we sort of go out the window, yet
the question is a good one because that has
happened in history.
But remember that much of the right doesn't
even see what happened on January 6th as terrorism.
And so I don't think that what is being proposed
as a possibility is actually going to happen.
OK, yeah.
All right, well, thanks so much for speaking
with me.
I really appreciate it.
Big fan.
Thanks, Stephanie.
Great to hear from you.
I appreciate it as well.